hello they reject nation I'm Greg Alba
what's your name I'll Pat Hogue Pat
Hogue the Canadian man who I've met at
the Schmo down we've become really good
friends he might get a little more
involved in this channel than you guys
even realize or even want how does that
make you feel it makes me feel good
because my years of stalking you without
you knowing has truly started to pay off
I appreciate that Pat you are quite
confident on camera over here I'm
nothing without my charisma we're gonna
watch the second trailer for x-men Dark
Phoenix right now John is actually
really under the weather so Pat's
filling in for him today what a good
first video for you to be a part of yeah
no this is kind of a big one I'm like
Greg this is my first reaction you'll be
great let's see if I screw this one up
now you're gonna be awesome you're gonna
be natural oh man I am just fully
prepared to give a 100% genuine reaction
for my first time as otherwise no
sarcasm I am literally going to ground
your channel oh yeah before we hop into
this I like to say a special thank you
to all you beautiful sons of [ __ ] and
bastards and [ __ ] and losers and
winners who have followed us on the
Stardust app it's free to download free
to use 30 second reaction reviews from
Philip TV show or trailer we post daily
Pat doesn't subscribe to us you should
you [ __ ] guys do it today you can
impose - let's watch this wasting too
much time
okay I just talked it a Phoenix Hoshi
totally kills mystique probably good for
damn my theory is correct she kills
Messiah so I could drive about this okay
interesting
star wars okay Mystique's funeral you
showed it one way to get actors out of
their contracts I love in cinematic it
looks food Quicksilver me
and they're really selling her has a
threat
yeah like the biggest one like they've
come a comical beast actions by the ex
is the expensive let it go far
and now the post credit teaser in the
trailer like Captain Marvel blowing
women you know giving the representation
they need God yeah all right we both
talked about a little bit before have we
both like the first trailer yeah and
this only amplifies it a lot more for me
like I really like how Simon Kimber's
kind of infusing some elements in here
that feel
yeah that's like you got some crazy-ass
[ __ ] and then you also have some like
grounded horror stuff going on it's the
thing of like I've always heard the
pitch for like what the Dark Phoenix
storyline was yeah how it kind of plays
off the fact of like who'd be scared of
Jean Grey and I'm like that's kind of
the same problem with the movie even
though they've tried to like build it up
but like yeah these so far these like
two trailers have done a really good job
of like know that she's got one some
deep-seated emotional issues and now
this like godlike power not a good combo
for her mouths I could come but they
still have I don't think they've
revealed who Jessica Chastain yeah Simon
Kinberg said in an interview a while ago
that she's a combination of two
characters of a couple of different
carriers yeah it's a two but you say
couple I assume two and in the Dark
Phoenix eight not eight to the Dark
Phoenix comic book there were two main
characters that yeah that kind of
flashed to mind here
lilandra from from the I think it's her
name from the Shire asa huh and then
jason wyngarde who's mastermind and only
comics so this is news to me don't say
that in the comic book video release
ending the plebeian nah fun combination
of two characters so I I'm at it seems
like what she's especially with like
pulling out you know the Phoenix with
Indian and forcing her to really hone in
I'm like what's really within her but
dude I mean when you piece together the
first trailer it really made it look
like mystique dies and then this trailer
makes it even like so much better that
mystique is gonna die boy oh boy
we show
why'd you do that to her that was my
friend and then a few and then I feared
all our friends at the funeral like if
you piece together the first trailer
like this looks like mystique dies but
in this one you're like are they just
making it like flat out clear let misty
it's like the exit universe is at such
like a weird point of like we know it
has to end after this cuz like dizzy
like they're going to file it's like
they can really go to those lengths of
like they can like do the dramatic beats
of like you see Magneto's skull getting
crushed in by a helmet ins like could
actually have his skull crushed Hey
John's uh storing us right now okay he's
sick so he's doing something productive
and he's story yes right I can't be
expecting one thing and it was not to be
filmed yeah John John the one
requirement I had anyway it would make
sense though mystique dies based off the
way if you piece you know the first in
the second trailer yeah there's that
thing where you do see magneto and gene
talking with each other where it looks
like he's trying to get her to embrace
it and yeah Sheik if she were to kill
him Asti couldn't make sense why might
need it would that turn on her well in
it and same thing with Charles while
they're all grieving and turning against
each other well you know and like with
the first trailer when Magneto's like
you didn't come here for like help you
came you you're asking for permission
you just like came here wanting her
maybe I had that backwards you didn't
come here looking for guidance you came
here asking for permission to do all
these horrible things and even Magneto's
like nah you're kind of you're good
you're down to a lot deeper darker
things and I'm I'm Magneto this trailer
seems edited a little funny because you
know how the end of this trailer they're
all they're all in a train they're all
arrested energy and they got the
caller's oh is that another one was like
we're oppressing mutant power thing and
then earlier but earlier you see like
beasts man whipping through and like
make me don't want to come and or a
scene of magneto they got me buddy this
oddly feels like the most like comic
book ii of all the accident i think its
aesthetic if someone disagree with me
hard like there are some comments i
really disagree with me on the past cons
but i think from their costumes and just
how personal and grounded it feels in
their world this is cinema tartar
yes much more like let's show case like
the weirdness of like all of this yes
all the elements going on and it feels
like it feels kind of scary at times
yeah I was like legit scary and you know
you I was cool that they guys showcase
some of the other pegs scene that shot a
beast I haven't even thought of the act
yeah yeah which is kind of funny then
you got some of this cosmic stuff going
on and then you know like crazy train
sequences and some space moments work
looks good is new elements for like kind
of an exponential for almost 20 years
and has kind of been hitting the same
beats and now we're finally getting to
the place of like magneto being you know
Charles what are we doing here
yeah and now Jean Grey is like I'm gonna
burn you all down let's see crazy let's
go over the top of this well if this is
the last like I know they have new
mutants which is coding as weird about
in the face but I think for x-men Dark
Phoenix if this is going to be the last
yeah one from them presumably I think
this would be a cool one for them to go
out on yeah the fact that it's not
apocalypse big bad guy we have to stop
because he wants to do bad things very
personal one to what the friend we've
had pretty much throughout the movies
that we've had the emotional arts with
yeah the villain we have to take down
that's a pretty good like template you
like have the emotional ending until
Mickey Mouse comes in I mean the gonna
actually know what's funny about the
magneto moment yeah it with the guns
that kind of reminds me the first x-men
when he uses all the gun I would add and
Charles has to stop the guns are the one
boy yeah man Derek is stopping it and
I'm like just move back like if it's
during hurt stop except letting this
bullet go into your skull dude except
these assault rifles while a cool moment
when you slow it down look really CGI
and before I wrap this video up I would
love course like to give a page of the
day shout out to a beautiful man his
name is Chris me Luke he leave Canada to
man Kenny and me it's not exactly what
you are but close enough a fellow Canuck
of eating your poutine and drinking your
Tim Hortons that's why I got him day
because I don't know
when he's talking about water fills
ice-hockey was why I'm here so he's been
a patron for just a short amount of time
but we've already had a lot of long
exchanges back and forth I love chatting
with this guy he's a photographer that's
his main passion Maya may you Mayu
photography and dis growing through his
Instagram he takes photos of just the
ugliest people ever like my god these
people are just so opposite of active
great actually some pretty attractive
people so I have no idea what hats the
sarcasm these chicks and men are haughty
I can deal it I can't breathe it yeah
and you don't get a beautiful picture he
just launched a new channel called new
stall Joe which is actually a really
interesting channel basically he just
looks back on a game from his past we're
playing the HD remaster remake version
and he showed me one for a Pokemon let's
go get you an Eevee and it was a really
good video manuscript these things
really well just let more of your humor
shine I'm gonna give you advice on
public let some of your personality
really Shemer than that you got your
analysis down to a tee you're taking
photos of hot men and women you're in
Canada which is one of the most violent
countries in the world so you are
obviously a tough cookie been around the
block you know what's what hope you had
sex it sells Chris you got it going a
lot of going on Chris he said we were a
big influence in him creating his
concept and I said why who says her
inspirations or whatever in your life is
not aa person you listen to it makes me
question you watching his back watching
my back anyway Chris thanks for being
here buddy you're such a sweet man I'm
happy to get to know you some more what
do you guys think of this x-men Dark
Phoenix trailer do you think Fox is
gonna say have a bit to do you know and
film your own youtuber question
subscribe to the reject nation click
that notification about downfalls and
start us up Pat the Canadian is pat the
canadian on Instagram I think go check
them out today solid please please
please